are you filming okay so tell me where  this came from it was a present from a  Thon's  it is a little crocheted Dominic is it  offend the UK or an American film AMA so  the problem I have with the stoic  because I have seen Doctor Who and I  know that they're supposed to be  intimidating is scary  is mostly because of the angle of the  nose and the hands it it looks really  harmless and actually kind of cute  um it looks like even if it came at you  it would have a cute squeaky little  voice and it would go look the nose  makes it actually look kind of shy  nothing knows is this tiny store it's  shy it wants to be friends but it's like  maybe you won't talk to me  then maybe you'll talk to me if I don't  exterminate exterminate exterminate